hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine where were you the
evening of September 24 2008 when
then-president George W Bush stood in
front of the nation and said well
normally I'm a strong believer in the
free enterprise system but reason knew
from that moment we had the biggest
economic and public policy fight on our
hands since the collapse of communism we
rededicate ourselves especially the
latter half of our long-standing motto
of free minds and free markets when
Washington bailed out Detroit we pointed
out not only is it asinine it's illegal
when bankrupt states came to Washington
for a handout we documented that no they
don't have a revenue problem they have a
spending problem and every time we've
heard happy talk from the administration
about creating or saving up to five
million jobs green or otherwise we have
pointed out in detail that these claims
are at best laughable we're only able to
do this thanks to the individual
contributions from people such as you
twenty dollars for a yearly subscription
that's it a hundred and you get an extra
subscription plus your choice of Brian
doherty's radicals for capitalism or
Peter bags everybody's stupid except for
me at two hundred and fifty dollars you
get all kinds of reasons sweg and for a
thousand you get the kind of benefits
that i can't legally say on television
remember when other people are coming
upon their libertarianism only when a
new administration comes to Washington
reason has been fighting for free minds
and free markets since literally before
I was born so support reason today thank
you